字幕: Genta Katakura
校正: Kazunori Akashi
最初に 皆さんに
こんな質問をできたらなと思っています
皆さんライターとストローの共通点って
何かご存じでしょうか
カタカナ４文字であること
カタカナ３文字プラス棒線があること
それ以外 一つ共通点があります
５秒 10秒くらい 考えてみましょう
その間に 僕の緊張が和らぐと思いますので
両手を空中に出してみてください
マッチを使ってみましょう
そしてライターを使ってみましょう
その通り
ライターというのは
片手のない障がい者が作ったものです
そして ストローというのは
首が座らない障がい者が作ったものです
私は 就労困難な方の雇用創造
そんな理念のもと NPO法人
フューチャードリームアチーブメントという
組織を経営しています
僕らがやっていきたいことは
当たり前を作っていくこと
ライター ストローを見て
皆さんが 白い杖や車いすのように
支援を受けていると思うでしょうか
ライターやストローは
欧米でもアジアでも皆さんの手元にある
どんな人だって働ける
そして 社会とつながれる
そんな当たり前を作っていきたいなと思って
この組織を経営しています
今日皆さんに一つだけ 伝えたいことがあって
僕は参りました
それは「大丈夫」っていう
メッセージです
大丈夫というメッセージです
皆さんが うつ病で
会社を辞めたとしても
皆さんが
シングルマザーになっても
定時制の学校を卒業しても
障害 引きこもり 生活保護
ホームレス 難民 難病
薬物依存 HIV 犯罪歴がある
若年性の認知症である
LGBTである 虐待を受けている
どんな人だって働ける
そして 社会とつながれる
そんな「大丈夫」という言葉を
皆さんに伝えたくて 今日は参りました
そろそろ僕の眼の話を
できたらいいなと思います
３歳の時にですね 家族みんなで
花火をしていました
「俊輔 燃えかすを
バケツの中に入れてごらん」と
母親に言われて
明るくきれいに映っていた
花火は見えていたんですけど
花火が消えた瞬間
僕は 暗闇を分からなくなってしまいました
そして バケツの中に
燃えかすを入れられなくなった
この子は暗いところが見えていない
そんなことに両親が気付き
全国の病院を回り
網膜色素変性症という病名が付きました
そして 私は普通の学校に行きました
小 中 高
小学校の頃はですね １メートル離れると
サッカーボール１個分見える範囲がありました
中学 高校でソフトボール
大学で500円玉
今は この光しか見えません
小 中 高 普通の学校に行ったんですね
普通の学校に行ってよかったなって
周りの人に言われるんです
いやいや ちょっと待ってね
僕は漫画とゲームと部活動ができませんでした
教室の中にしか支援ってないんです
教科書を大きくしてくれたり
でもね 僕には部活動ができなかったので
ルール 仲間 達成感 一体感
そんな言葉が全然分からなかった
そして 漫画やゲームができないので
人と話すネタがありませんでした
そして 小中高と学期に１回
眼の病院に通います
目の見えない僕に対して
先生方はこう言うんです
「点字を覚えるといいよ」って
「白い杖をつけるといいよ」
「パソコン使えると便利だよ」って言うんです
いやいや待ってねって
白い杖をついて 出かける先がないから
困っているのに
点字を覚えて誰とやり取りしたらいいか
困ってるのにって
パソコンを読んで
どんな情報を得られたら
この心がすっきりするか分かるのに
分からないから困っているのにって
富士山を上るうえで大事なことは
靴でもウェアでも戦略でもないです
ご来光がきれいなことを忘れないこと
支援の現場では この目的と手段が
ひっくり返ることがよくあります
僕は「働けるの？」って そして
「光って見え続けるの？」って
そんなことを言ってほしかったです
そんな中 18年間は暗黒時代でした
今は 人様の前でこうやって
毎日のように話しますけど
おそらく １日に今喋る量がですね
10年前の３か月分くらいかなと思います
（笑）
「はい」くらいしか
言えませんでした
そんな中 ３つのターニングポイントが
ありました 僕には
１回目のターニングポイント
僕は ２年間引きこもったんです
障害をもって 目が見えなくて
俺みたいな人って
どうやって生きてるのかなと思って
東京に出てきました
そして福祉を勉強することにしました
自分の存在を示すために
自分の価値は勉強しかないって思っていたので
努力している成澤君
勉強ができる成澤君
偏差値をとれる成澤君
僕自身に価値がないから
この形容詞や副詞に力を入れようと
で 大学２年生の時にある必修科目が
不可になっちゃったんです
人生が終わったと思ったんです
人生がって
目が見えなくて留年している
目が見えなくて引きこもり
目が見えなくて不登校
俺捨てられるんちゃうかなと思って
明日行こう 明日行こう
と思っていたら
学校に２年間行けなかったんです
ちょっと変わってるんです
恋人にも 家族にも 友達にも
誰にも言わなかったんです
丸２年間 社会とつながりながら
こんな１日です
九州から 母が
年に１、２回くらい来るわけですよ
学校行ってくるねと言って
近くのマックに隠れてました
そして 恋人が急に泊まりに来たりすると
「今日授業じゃなかった？」
いや早く終わったんだよみたいな感じで
そして 盆と暮れも
ちゃんと九州に帰ってたんですよ
今の時代 就活って結構大変だよって
ぜーんぶ嘘です
ぜーんぶ嘘
そんな中 大学４年生の社会福祉の
国家試験のその日も僕は嘘をついていました
だから 弟からメールが来たんです
「お兄ちゃん今日国家試験頑張ってね」って
俺家にいるんだけどなって思いながら
そのメールを受け取りました
で 手元には合格祈願のお守りが
いっぱいありました もらったものが
合格祈願より俺は祈りたいことが
あるぜって思ってました
そして１日 反省文のように
メールを書いてたんです
裏切ってごめんなさいっていうメールを
そして国家試験が終わった時間の頃
メールを送りました
みんなは 無事に終わったよって
メールかと思ったんですけど
「ごめんなさい
学校に２年行ってませんでした」
誰も責めなかったです
そして 父はこう言ってくれた
「俊輔もスーパーマンじゃ
なかったんだな」って
僕ね 失敗したことなかったんですよ
大学２年生まで
失敗したら捨てられると思っていたので
その時 親父に愛されてるなと思いました
１個目の引きこもったことによって
僕は自分で人生で選んで
初めて失敗するという経験ができました
そして ２つ目に
皆さんよく僕こうやってお話をするんで
「何の仕事されてるんですか？」
大体「営業のお仕事ですか？」って
言われるんですけど
あ ごめんなさい 会社を経営していますって
こんなことがありました
当事者として悶々として東京に出てきて
そして福祉を勉強したら
もっと悶々としたんですよ
だって 40、50代の健常者の先生が
「障がい者ってな」って授業するんです
いやちょっと俺20年だぜって
思ったりとか
クラスメイト９割女子で
ゲームしながら授業受けてるんです
僕いままで 慣れと経験と勘とキャラで
生きてきたんですよ
慣れと経験と勘とキャラ
で 誤魔化しながら生きてきたんですよ
そしたら 福祉が障がい者の大変さを
いっぱい僕に見せつけてきたんで
「やべえ 居れないこの業界に」と思って
そんな中 僕は経営という仕事に出会いました
20歳前後の頃
大変でしたよ
入社倍率４千倍くらいの会社にいました
30名のコンサルタントで
１万社くらいの会社の
IPOやM&Aや
役員の紹介業をお手伝いしている会社に
僕は大学行きながら 有償の
インターンシップに行くことになりました
いっぱい良いことがあったんです
始発から終電まで仕事して
毎晩のように会食があって
夜中に資料が作れなかったら
親にお願いしたりとかしてました
でも そんな中
まず１つ目
人生で初めて結果を求められたんですよ
結果を
今まで結果を求められたことがなかったんです
１位から最下位まで営業成績が出る会社でした
そして 不謹慎ながらも僕が数字を外すと
上司が謝ってくれるんです
で それ見てて
「いや 成澤が数字を外したのは
私のせいです」って謝ってるの見て
幸せだったんですよ
愛されてるって
ずっと自分ひとりで生きていたのが
結果を求められた
それは 自分の辞書に
相手というのが生まれたんですよ
お客様とか 部下とか チームっていうのが
超幸せだなって思って
そんな中 飛び込み営業しながら
20歳前後の僕に経営のアドバイスなんか
何もできなかったんです
でも 皆さん最後に こう言ってくれたんです
「成澤君 また会いに来てくれよ」って
なぜかっていうと 経営者の孤独と
就労困難な僕の孤独が一緒だったんです
答えのない苦しみに向き合っている
人に必要とされたり
褒められる機会がほとんどない
だから 僕はその頃これだけ目を近づけたら
まだ資料が見えてました
杖をつきながら
なんかできることないですかって
その試行錯誤してる感が
なんか近かったんでしょうね
そこから僕は 経営者の孤独に
向き合う仕事をしようと決めたんです
恋人でも友達でも家族でも
先生でも医療者でもなく
僕を最初に必要としてくれたのは
経営者だったんです
だから 僕は２つ目の
経営という仕事に出会ってですね
初めて自分の辞書に相手というものが生まれて
自分の人生が変わりました
で 今度３つ目
僕いま この光しか見えないんですよ
10年前に失明をしました
失明したんですけど
そんな大変なことないんです
今 職員が約20名
就労困難なトレーニングを受けている
メンバーが約80名
100名の組織を束ねてます
そんなに難しくないです
失明をして１個だけ困ったことがあるんです
皆さん何だと思います？
失明をして
それは 鏡の前で
自分の存在が分からなくなったことです
失明するまで 偏差値や売上っていうのに
一生懸命すがっていました
失明をしてですね 僕は
1つの癖が増えたんです
手を掻く癖が
それは自分を探してるんです
自分の存在って何だろうって
誰か教えてくれよって
もう偏差値や売上 そして
色んな武器を持とうと思ったんですけど
それじゃあ 僕の心の
ドキドキは止まらなかったんです
自分のどこ行った？って
俺どこ行った？って思うようになりました
自分の存在って何だろうって
皆さんもそうじゃないですか
お母ちゃんも サラリーマンも
学生も 経営者も
自分の存在って何だろうって
皆さん思いますよね
僕は 先ほど話したように
ちょっと変わってるんです
父が国内随一の名医で
お姉ちゃんがガンで死んで
僕は難病で 僕は帰国子女で
僕は普通校に無理やり行って
大学７年通って うち２年間引きこもって
大学在学中から経営の仕事して
３年前には 髄膜炎という病気で死にかけてる
色んな社会課題が僕に降ってくるんです
でも 見ていただいて分かるように
僕ね 幸せなんです
今 100名の組織を束ねてます
97％就労困難者なんです
17歳から68歳まで
40以上の病気を持ったメンバーが
僕の部下にいます
それでも 幸せなんです
毎日誰か自殺未遂します
毎日誰か入院をします
そして たまに
訴えるぞって言われます
（笑）
それでもね 幸せなんです
だから 皆さんに言われるんです
「成澤さん その笑顔の原点は何ですか」って
なんかやっちゃってるんじゃないですか
みたいな
いやいや そんなことないですよ
その笑顔の原点は何ですかって言われたら
僕はいつもこう答えます
今あなたが
笑顔って言ってくれたことですよって
自分の存在って何だろうって
モヤモヤしながら
ずっと自分のことって
自分で示さなあかんなって思ってたんですよ
違かったんです
相手がいるから自分がいるんです
そういうことに失明を通して気付けたんです
だから もう手の傷ないんです
皆さんがこうやって拍手したり
笑ってくださって
あ 俺もう 分からないけど
皆さんに示してもらって
このドキドキが止まったんです
だから いま僕がやってる仕事っていうのは
誰かの相手になるって仕事なんです
３千万人の就労困難者
そして 400万人の経営者に
大丈夫だぜって言うのが仕事
ここの隣にいる人たちはいつも
「とは言え」、「どうせ」
「だって」って言う人たちです
その人たちに「大丈夫だから」って
「俺がいるからさ」って言うのが僕の仕事です
３つのターニングポイント
引きこもって初めて
人生で失敗することができて
人を頼れるようになった
経営という仕事に出会って 自分の辞書に
相手というものが生まれた
そして 失明をして誰かの相手になる
相手が自分を示してくれる
そんなことに気付くことができました
そんな中 いま僕が何をやっているか
３つの仕事をしています
仕事の５割は 障がい者雇用とか
多様な働き方改革という領域の
コンサルティングをしています
全国で そして １業界１社しか
クライアントを持たないです
そして 必ず経営者に出てきてもらいます
なので リサイクル屋さんから
産廃の会社から 清掃の会社から 飲食店から
木くず屋さんから 桶屋さんから
印刷の会社から
40以上の業界業種を見ています
なんでかって言うと
皆に選ばしてやりたいんですよ
色んな仕事あるぜって
で 色んな業界でこの支援をすることによって
宮崎でも 北海道でも 広島でも
皆を幸せにすることができる
私の１つの仕事は 障がい者雇用の
コンサルタントをしています
おそらく日本でトップのコンサルタントだと
領域や定着率の点から見てもそうだと思います
２つ目に 年間相談を約２千件くらい受けます
２千件くらい 当事者や家族の
人の視線が怖くて髪の毛がここまである人
身長がこれくらいしかない人とか
犯罪歴が７犯ある人とか
LGBTの人
色んな人たちに毎日のように会います
そして言うんです 彼らに
「大丈夫だぜ」って
そして３つめに 講演や研修をしています
年に200くらいスピーチや挨拶
講演 研修する機会があります
なぜなら この取り組みを今日知れば
無理心中する家族が減ると思っています
この取り組みを今日知れば
障害を持つ子供を殺す
お母ちゃんが減ると思います
この取り組みを今日知れば
うつ病で自殺する人が減るかなと思っています
で 200のうち100くらいが
無料やボランティアです
なんで 私自身は
大丈夫って皆さんに言うために
企業さんのコンサルティングをし
当事者にダイレクトに会い
そして 講演 研修をしています
そんなことをしていたら
色んな結果が 出てきました
写真も映ると思いますけれども
20年間引きこもっていた人が
３年トレーニングを受けて
ITの会社で正社員で働いています
写真に写っているのは
50代で 障害が５種類もある人が
正社員でボーナスをもらいながら
働いています
でも 心配なんで２か月に１回くらい
そろそろリストラですか？って
メール送るんですけど
「いや されねーし」って
で 「ボーナスが少ない」って言ってきたら
いや貰ってるだけええやんって話で
５年間引きこもってる人が
僕とメールを３往復しただけで
家から出てきたりします
そんなことができています
誰だって働ける
働くというのは フルタイム働けて
空気が読めて 愛想笑いができて
エクセルができて
プレゼンができてじゃないです
それだったら僕 プレゼンしかできないんで
でも 一応幸せに
世界中で仕事をさせて頂いてます
働くって強みが１個あればいい
弱みを受け止められる素直さが１個あればいい
僕は 世界一明るい視覚障がい者という
キャッチコピーを持っています
それはなぜか
10年前のある日 トイレで
ポッとこの言葉を思いついたんですよ
不安だったんでしょう
40歳から60歳くらいで
光を失うというこの病気が
だから 僕はこのキャッチコピーをつけました
明るく生きたいなって
で 暗いときこの明るいモードに
入っていけるので
で 僕はまだ未練があるみたいです
明るく生きといた方が 長く光って
見えるんちゃうかなって思ってるんでしょう
でも もう進行が進んできました
おそらく あと数年で僕は光を失うでしょう
それでも 世界一明るい視覚障がい者―
そんな生き方ができる
準備できたんじゃないかって
周りの人に言われてるような気がします
今日いらっしゃっている皆さんに届けたい
どんな人だって働ける
社会とつながれる
大丈夫だぜって
そんな言葉を贈れたらなと
そして皆さんも
既に誰かにとっての相手になっている
そんなことに気付いていただけたらな
という風に思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）